[Music]
when fortnight battle royale came out
most people thought that fortnight
eSports was a pipe dream the worst
possible game to be an eSport game is
fortnight I don't think there's any way
that game ever becomes good
competitively fortnight quickly became a
phenomenon thanks to being fun to play
perfect for three men and always
changing thanks to a near constant
stream of updates but competitive for
tonight from server issues to bloom to
stream sniping to the aforementioned
updates destroying any hope of
consistency there were a lot of
obstacles in the way of anybody trying
to take the game seriously enter T Fuu
and closing two friends who paired
jaw-dropping talent with the meme build
world of twitch streaming sprinkled it
with a dose of clout gang shenanigans
and proceeded to dominate the twisted
landscape of competitive fortnight cloak
C ticking on down just 20 health raid
against water you are the number one -
oh how are you guys feeling right now
I don't have where's shadows all the
fans they emerge from a landscape that
everybody thought would be ruined by RNG
and appearance and they dominated it
competition might never be fortnight's
focus but closely and T Fuu were the
first tool to show us what's really
possible for the game
[Music]
the relationship between T foo and cloak
C goes all the way back to each one's he
wins a battle royale mode a king of the
kill while they moved in the same
circles they didn't actually play
together that much until way after the
death of h1z1 and even after their time
in pub G oh my god in February 2018
after Chloe had made a name for himself
by posting fortnight clips on social
media faze clan approached him with an
offer of making a competitive fortnight
roster it was his big break so being
part of team is like tremendously
changed my life I would never expect to
be we're actually living in LA now I was
living alone and well with two other
roommates in Texas I moved back to New
Jersey I didn't expect anything you know
I was I was pretty much a no-name mein
name for myself was posting clips to
Twitter and stuff like that and fries
reach out to me back in February and
they're like hey we're extremely
interested we want you to build a team
and I was like this is like top of the
line like faze clan like came to me and
wanted me to go the team the original
lineup consisted of space lion Gamma 72
hours and closing cloak Cena faze clan
were looking for a fourth
but not just any fourth they were
looking for a dynamic player with
superstar potential they were looking
for an answer
yeah dude I just gave him a call I don't
know he's doing it in answer
unfortunately Adam
before he signed with phase on April
30th people was doing decent numbers on
YouTube but he wasn't the phenomenon
that we know him as today but he was
still teasing you to come for the insane
gameplay but you'd stay for the
laid-back atmosphere and the cheeky
attitude he just as quickly referred to
himself as an asset fortnight as he
casually drop a 20
Jiji 23 kills not bad man by signing
Teague face claim took on a world-class
talent who was down to cloud someone
with the raw ability to backup the cloud
someone who cloaks he could not only pal
around with on vlogs and on streams but
a natural-born competitor with the
talent to dominate the world a fortnight
[Music]
nice play passive you got this
nice crush P cross P if ninja drew kids
to fortnight on the back of a family
friendly personality and daytime
streaming teeth woolen cloak scene
offered something different the embodied
the clout mentality that faze clan had
been all about since the early days of
call duty they are here to rack up kills
and talk [ __ ] whether you like them or
not this new and improved phase plan
coincided with Epic Games 100 million
dollar prize pool announcement for the
2018 2019 season and in the meantime
guys today I ran like a giant fortnight
tournament with like all the biggest
youtubers and streamers Friday fortnight
is gonna be a weekly thing every single
Friday and like everyone was in it like
Logan Paul Feig's Banks nadeshot myth
fortnight Fridays a weekly tournament
with thousands of dollars going to the
winners it saw two duo teams squad up
together and then compete against each
other for the highest kill counts and as
the competitive fortnight landscape
began to take shape in the summer of
2018
Shifu and Lok si took off like a rocket
ship out of the ten weeks that fortnight
Fridays ran before Epic Games shut it
down ki foo and cloak Siwon for $20,000
tournaments and came second in another
and while the summer skirmish at the
game's first attempt that competitive
fortnight was less impressive
the duo's best was still yet to come
[Music]
not to introductory three turn it on
beaming them man
I need Emma pushing all right easy level
BOTS this is easy pushing
[Music]
come on
another one under me got him girl then
let's go baby
popped off with that eight kills real
quick kit fever just dead oh let's go
he's got raped over this guy's actually
a decent player bro you might kill that
let's go we win let's go baby
I don't know I did it I don't know what
just keeps playing up
[Music]
we're decoding
but
yeah competing in solos tp1 both week
two and four with cloak see close behind
all of it was building towards a
gigantic week six finale at twitchcon on
the biggest competitive stage fortnight
had ever seen Teague and cloaks he
finally had a chance to show exactly why
they deserve to be the best in the world
s now the ten HD back out dude it gets
the knock on caster shots excellent just
like that capitalizing I mean this is
this is their job zone
who gets a shot there on flowers and yet
seem absolutely three let's ditch the
limbs combined right now yep
any sort of placement point that they're
not close enough right now which means
if they get the elimination T foo and
cloaker they're - they're gonna have to
look out top 13d folks he's still alive
member coming into this neighbor already
first in points after game one there's
one for cloak seat 11 players now left
how about another as more begin to drop
Bob down he's gonna crap Bluff to the
high ground
you've got snoop snoot on the high
ground as well he's got it walls T 4
o'clock C with another will get the
extra point for the victory royale the
sole moving on in only 29 health for my
trow this this zone will chuck it up
down there's the quick shot from here oh
the double barrels so good at the G food
looks like he's ready for the heal it's
not gonna come on in teeth the watch by
the trees but hero
rob to by the storm and just like that T
foo and cloak scene set the tone and
prove why they are two of the favorites
here this weekend it was more than just
an epic performance fee foo and cloaks
he dominated over the course of several
days and it felt expected as if they
were exactly where they were supposed to
be flames got everything you get ever
need two cloaks he's trying to shoot
down this top side so they can't heal
can they do it there's a three players
left they're dropping him on down will
they be able to out survive this zone
they're floating tea boo still not he
can't use his heels closing ticking on
down just 20 health remaining gets Wanda
they completely dead one are you kidding
me the last second push out into the
storm may have changed that game from a
third or second to a first place to hunt
the royale so when they walked away with
half a million dollars in prize money it
made sense and people in cloaks II knew
it coming out of the ball skirmish six
weeks of work pays off on this stage
right now in front of all of you in
front of all of you at home you're
number one duo
[Music]
it's day five and while the dual was on
fire in terms of popularity twitchcon
was their competitive peak while they
finished 2018 on top the new year
brought some unexpected developments
that threatened to blow up everything
they've been working towards behind the
scenes Teague and cloaks T were dealing
with serious contract disputes which
eventually led to t Fuu one of the most
popular streamers on Twitch deciding to
sue the organization that helped him get
there
so T Fuu is suing faze clan now the
lawsuit starts out by alleging that faze
clan is trying to port on quote own t
food they refer to his contract
bizarrely as a gamer agreement and they
call it quote mostly oppressive onerous
and one-sided friendly chief who's suing
phase and my chat saying it's no cap are
you serious I mean that's what they're
telling me but I still don't believe
them T foo Sue's organization /
oppressive contract what from a cause
that prohibited t food from streaming
for up to six months if he left the org
to his contract just being straight-up
illegal according to his lawyer the
match made in heaven
was crumbling and T foo wanted out this
is [ __ ] [ __ ] show the [ __ ]
contract this release the [ __ ]
contract everybody
hashtag release the [ __ ] contract
release it it is 80% company 20% to t
foo that's how it's written that may not
be their intentions after he blew up but
if you're in t food shoes you don't take
that chance right you have to get out of
that contract as quick as possible
now that you're making millions of
dollars and well T fo was dealing with a
controversy that set the streaming world
on fire cloak C was quietly contending
with very similar issues hoax he began
removing phase logos from his social
media platforms and twitch presence
before eventually revealing but yes he
was trying to leave phase and in fact he
actually had been for the last six
months we are trying to resolve
something to make it so
I will leave face we haven't been in
agreement with me leaving for the past
six months because they've been trying
to leave for the past six months before
the Holte food thing came out I mean you
guys saw the contract along the same
exact contract the exact [ __ ] per
sentence yes I was offered other
contracts and we couldn't come to a
conclusion through all of this t foo and
closed he remained tight and the plan
was at least as far as anybody can tell
for them to move in together and film
some cloud content whatever the hell
that is the elephant in the room me and
Turner are still going to be dual
partners the intern are still homies
there's nothing different between me and
carrion at all so brothers are still
gonna fly out on the world cup we're
still gonna win the World Cup we're
gonna pop off in the midst of all this
mess
they still had fortnight and they still
had their friendship there have been
some more bumps in the road Shore they
didn't qualify for the World Cup
together and T foo has teamed up with
faced way and clicks to form a new trio
but as far as anyone can tell they're
still tight
they even followed through on their plan
to move in together coming back to
stream together for the first time after
the World Cup on July 30th
oh and whatever happens from here ki foo
and cloak see they remind us all of a
time that feels vaguely familiar of
hanging out with our friends without for
a brief moment on care in the world
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]